donc il est bien évident que vous dirai
pas ce qui se passe pendant la garde à
vue
j'ai vu au travers de la presse vous
allez mettez un club de captieux devrait
être atteint des seuils cinquantaine de
cas ce n'est pas ce que j'ai été porté à
ma connaissance dans le cadre de la
garde à vue c'est très loin d'être une
cinquantaine de cas il n'a pas été mis
en garde à vue pour 50 cas ce n'est pas
une réalité
il va être entendu par contre je suis
extrêmement surpris voire
particulièrement agacés du fait que des
fuites existent concernant l'existence
de cette garde à vue
j'aurais souhaité qu'on soit beaucoup
plus discret comme on avait été au
départ de cette procédure parce qu'on
est sur un dossier extrêmement délicat
laissé sont particulièrement contestée
et contestable et j'ai peur que cette
publicité qui a été donnée à cette garde
à vue n'a que pour seule finalité c'est
d'essayer de cautionner un dossier qui
je n'ai déjà bien de ces d'instruction
qui je l ai déjà dit est de plus en plus
fragile les indices
on ne parle en tout cas pas de 50 ans
mais très en dessous de 50 cas on est
sur un nombre de cas importants mes
passions 50 cas ce n'est pas la réalité
de son placement en garde à vue nous
demanderons procureur de la république
combien exactement c'était pas simple
dans quel état d'esprit utiles à votre
client une garde à vue sinon c'est une
violence donc c'est très très difficile
maintenant avec le docteur fait chier
avec maître leborgne avec notre béthune
de moro a décidé de se battre fed avait
péché et combatif il donne ses
explications et il répondra aux
questions des enquêteurs
ça fait déjà deux ans donc il mise en
examen il cette nouvelle vague qui
arrive extrêmement difficile puis la
famille aussi qui subit toute cette
procédure on aimerait bien que ça
s'arrête on a envie comme tout le monde
d'arriver à la vérité que son dossier se
termine comme ça raison pour laquelle
bien sûr on va collaborer dans le cadre
de sa garde à vue va être prolongée
c'est une évidence mais en dehors de
cela parce que je sais que beaucoup de
questions doivent être posées
donc à partir de ce moment là on va y
répondre qu'est ce qu'il adviendra de la
suite de cette procédure de garde à vue
en l'état il est impossible de faire de
pronostic
qu'est ce qu'il répond je ne suis pas en
mesure de vous dire quelles sont les
réponses que fait le docteur pêcher ni
quelles sont les questions qui lui sont
posées tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le docteur peschier est
aujourd'hui la même chose
il vous n'a jamais
appliquez de quelques poissons de son
choix dans un acte
dans un acte empoisonne ses positions
toujours sa position à l'heure où je
vous parle je suis profondément
persuadés comme ses avocats que le
docteur pesci gardera bien évidemment
cette cette même défense pour vous et la
victime d'un acharnement alors vous
parler d'acharnement jeu jeu
effectivement je peux dire que je vous
dis j'ai le sentiment qui est une sorte
d'acharnement judiciaire
le fait d'avoir rendu publique cette
garde à vue qui aurait dû rester secret
tu le fais effectivement d'essayer
d'intoxiquer plus ou moins l'opinion
publique est de mettre une sorte de
pression sur les magistrats qui gère ce
dossier
pour moi oui effectivement il ya un
acharnement celui ou celle qui a rendu
d'ailleurs public cette garde à vue agi
avec des intentions tout à fait
malveillantes vis-à-vis du docteur que
chier ou en tout cas procéduralement
malveillantes vis-à-vis du docteur péché
je ne sais pas qui c'est mais en tout
cas c'est quelque chose que nous
subissons que je déplore est-ce que vous
surpris bien sûr moi je ne m'attendais
pas une nouvelle garde à vue
ça fait plus de deux ans on nous parle
de cas supplétifs sans jamais avoir vu
le moindre cas supplétif
vous m'excuserez mais madame morisod
avait dit après mars 2017 attendait 6
mois à temps des huit mois et vous
verrez bien les dossiers que nous allons
ramener ça fait plus de deux ans qu'elle
avait fait ses déclarations
oui aujourd'hui en état nous sommes
particulièrement surpris je vous
rappelle qu'on a un dossier
d'instruction qui je vais toujours dit
n'a aucunes preuves impliquant
directement le docteur pêcher dans les
faits qui lui sont reprochés extrêmement
fragile
nous avons ici un dossier pour l'instant
que je ne connais pas ce que je n'ai pas
encore eu accès aux éléments de la
procédure qui je ne suis pas persuadé
soit beaucoup plus solide que le dossier
que nous avons à l'instruction
vous aviez soulevé il ya quelques mois
un problème de retranscription de la
précédente garde à vue où on avait cette
cette affaire alors même je suis très
surpris que effectivement la possibilité
que des enquêteurs visé dans la plainte
puisse continuer à prendre part à des
investigations dans le dossier du
docteur péché voire même puisse procéder
à des auditions ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
mais j'espère effectivement ce ne sera
pas le cas puisque nous avons déposé une
plainte circonstancié avec des faits
extrêmement graves
on a altéré la vérité de procès verbaux
nous avons saisi le doyen des juges
d'instruction pour l'instant nous
n'avons toujours pas de réponse
mais vous comprenez bien que l'ambiance
est particulièrement tendue dans un
dossier extrêmement complexe avec des
enquêteurs
certains enquêteurs qui ont été mis en
cause par les avocats de la défense qui
circulent serial killer
c'est consternant c'est totalement
consternants franchement quand on voit
l'absence d'épaisseur l'absence de
preuve qu'il ya dans le dossier
d'instruction
oser qualifier le docteur gachet de
serial killers et irresponsable
totalement irresponsables ont pas
oublier que cet homme là ce qu'il a vécu
depuis sa mise en examen ce que sa
famille a vécu 6 30 secondes
plutôt que de penser comme le procureur
de la république de l'époque il était
effectivement coupable avant qu'il soit
jugé
et bien si cet homme là est innocent je
ne sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
des dégâts qui ont été occasionnés à lui
à sa femme à ses enfants et à toute sa
famille l'affubler d'un tel qualificatif
c'est totalement irresponsable